um that's slightly wrong near this
screen now that's better welcome to this
video playing a five minute game here
against I ASD oh okay Kings gambit okay
I'm going to play them this wacky
counter gambit with f5 the adelaide
counter gambit usually irritating people
sometimes I retain myself but it's a fun
opening let's see what he's doing the
best reply is supposed to be a FD three
it looks kind of strange but I'm also
not so sure about it takes a five that's
also quite decent what white cannot do
is take on e5 that's really not working
so let's see what is coming up with it
just it may tempos at least no quick
reply now if you've never seen it that's
really tricky FTC 5 I take efore that's
really awkward at 9595 fe5 tweenage
forecheck is very well known way to lose
the game I mean mostly from from other
openings this when the f pawn is missing
the Queen age four things say they gain
and strength enormously so let's see
okay yeah that's that's one of the best
better moves definitely so here ya Queen
h5 sir is a threat so I have to react to
that and my ideas just d5 Bishop takes
f5 getting that in would be nice one
thing I have to be aware i cannot easily
play age 60 k he wants to play Bishop
to h5 check it seems ok so d phi of this
check know that that is something so i
have to have to take our worth of that
but how exactly hmm it gives a check
king is 79 f 7 is hitting not so easy i
don't well here I don't really know the
theory of this is just that I know it
exists and I play it for fun sometimes
in blitz and it is fun it's just a
completely wacky okay I have an idea i'm
not sure if it is working but I'm going
to try Bishop h5 check king is self
check night f7 Queenie 89 takes h eight
and then night takes h5 trying to pick
up pick up this night in the corner hmm
how wacky is that very you back here I'm
going to try now you can play other
moves for example a three or so but ok
this is really fun threatening night
takes h5 winning a piece so he has to
take the rook there is no no big
alternative to that one the real
question is do I get this night or not
it's not so easy it's not so easy to get
em ok is taking his time here don't know
i don't think that there are really
other mousse possible the question is
now take with what with the Queen
probably to get to get Queens traded
it's a my king is really
really insecure so probably this is what
I need to do it's not so easy to get
this night it really isn't if I move my
king yeah is going forward for the
cheeky I am Bishop a three check very
very tricky but if i take here with a
tick here check King f6 and then there
are yeah that's okay maybe Bishop checks
route chicks is fine yeah I'm picking up
the night then now if he gives check on
be too I have maybe even d4 but check at
deform before them somewhat risky
looking move kingi fixes the alternative
I mean this is also no but this this is
looking okay right I can I can play
Knight f6 next and then Bishop out and
pick up the night that looks kind of
logical
or even bishop out immediately as the h5
night is protecting g7 ma say what you
want i haven't the pieces that i have
out I active yeah here i was thinking
night g3 as a move i think i will go for
that the night is the night is pen sorry
I'm very irritating for wide and this is
luke he is almost almost trapped let's
see yeah if I move move this now he can
take g7 however I have Bishop c5 Bishop
c5 Bishop g7 Bishop g1 and this will win
the whole rock it just completely
bonkers disposition buts okay it seems
to work
the bishop on h2 and so it looks really
weird but don't see how it wraps it and
this would be an extra piece after
Bishop g1 and picks up the rook
yeah I think I'm winning here this is
wiki opening has probably found the
victim again I think the main problem a
little bit with this with this line and
there might be some of just objective
problems but he is completely playing
into the type of position that the Kings
gambit player once it's very
psychologically accommodating let's say
okay do I want to take I mean now I can
also just take on d4 and then pick up
the night this is easier right this is
easier now this is just a great position
with no problems whatsoever maybe he
could have played king f2 by the way
that would have been interesting you're
doing this too ok I can pick up the
night anyway and here and sorry this way
I'm keeping keeping excellent control if
I go back now not be five might happen
maybe let's do that yes I straight stuff
I'm in a position here where it is very
difficult for him to ever move the rock
now I'm taking this piece yeah I know
this is very very nice rook f8f for and
mate oh he's maybe getting it out quite
resigned he resigned yeah i'm going to i
mean f i can still play evade with this
idea and made i'm on ff1 twice yeah that
what a wacky opening I really have to it
here that is probably kind of a
theoretical position
after after this 95 96 Bishop e2 this is
probably something that is known but it
don't ask me I have no idea my idea is
of course yeah I don't know it might be
might be just totally bad but I thought
it was it was interesting yeah okay and
T I am I don't know it looks very
strange but it is it's very often a bit
tricky proposition to get this night out
it's funny the computers is saying equal
stock which is giving it is equal and
wants to play G form very aggressive
move on g4 I'd wants to reply 94 now i
have a temporary some temporary activity
I with the nights out here and so on
it's really weird what did he do be
three after that i'm clearly better
already yeah yeah i had the suspicion
but I mean I wasn't wasn't really sure
it looks like the night is not getting
out and I'm better I'm very much in the
game with all pieces so it is such a is
a nice position now but what about this
G form but what idea is that if i take
okay i understand he wants to just the
computer just wants to keep this porn
here place this okay so what does it
wants to play this move g 494 while that
sets really a strange
and this is how the line continues here
and now the fantastic moved g6 Wow this
idea
no hard time to just remotely
understanding what's going on yet Bishop
g7 look at one that's a computer's main
line which is assessed is equal this is
0 0 0 according to the engine yeah isn't
it great we don't understand anything
about chess champ Uman beings what what
kind of thing is that I have no idea
what yeah O'Gara in the game he went
here and hope that from here I didn't
allow much kingi six yeah King you sick
sauce maybe just better right yeah check
but ok I think it is it is a fine
position in any case this is this and
now I'm Bishop d6 is good but this is
also fine right now a black black is
wind cell here I can of course I can
also just take and go for this but ok I
thought that this is very simple you
know I'm picking up the the night I'm
material up and well this is just funny
here check yeah so I think this was
pretty em okay at the end yeah this is a
really really funky line I mean it's
it's only recommended to play in let's
say it's very in unimportant games or
games where you want to have some fun if
you don't like losing it's very very
risky stuff okay i hope you liked it
thanks for watching